[Music]
in cop Rober news submitted by failed
new year's goal together you got 10 more
months to work on it a North Carolina
deputy has been arrested in connection
to an armed robbery of a bank Wow
inside job Oh sounds like a movie to me
yeah I don't [ __ ] know I'm just
saying the deputy is supposed to protect
the loss well I just say it's a cop it's
not someone that works at the but yeah
it's true but you do have a good cop
homey oh it's a side inside there's
someone robbing us and then the cops
like I'm rather you [ __ ] as a don't
move II how do people get away with
robbing banks I heard there's a got
system right cuz don't you like giving
away like fake money or like the money
that's easily trackable or some [ __ ]
inkblot for small towns that get oh yeah
they don't got that fiberglass team they
all know everyone by first name go watch
the town like their money is just in
like burlap sack backs with the money
side and it's already counted for you
yeah how much would you like sir two
million here yeah yeah so this is Jeff
51 years old he looks like a Jeff yeah
yeah yeah so he's a deputy
apparently he walked up to a fmm bank
and then demanded money I want a big
[ __ ] Amata
MMMF Bank it's a fnm [ __ ] [ __ ]
your mother come on a financial [ __ ] so
Jeff walks in and he pulls out a black
block 42 why's it gotta be black that's
the color look I don't know why they
have to give you the color of the gun
all right anyway yeah one's got to be
black ice huh yeah he's gotta be a black
Glock do come in different colors green
tan
I like black box you can get custom
colors as well say that three times real
bad black box black box [ __ ] what clock
they gave him about a thousand bucks and
then when I'm not worth it his guns
balls look out long could've robbed some
rims a little bit of a buzz but well if
you think about it how long does it take
to rob probably a minute I don't know
he made a thousand bucks a minute this
big sucks though yeah yeah this is all
we got I want to took a stapler on the
way out to water bottle too I'm thirsty
four minutes later after he robbed the
bank he was caught he sucks yeah you
have a getaway car just on foot got back
on his horse
yeah he must be a big trouble he doesn't
make enough as a cop I don't know why he
decided to do this either like there's
no reason midlife crisis really well he
told the clerk was I need money he lost
he's a gambler Oh what if you didn't
even mean to rob it and then that's how
the teller like he was just like
literally I need money but he forgot to
say from what about the gun Oh black
Glock that part yeah black was he also
in uniform like a idiot
no now be funny I know you forgot to
change scooby-doo episode is really bad
yeah I know what I've gotten away with
it too
pesky kids this takes place in North
Carolina North Carolina not really Fried
Chicken Bojangles is that yes a lot of
[ __ ] happening
North Carolina and the incest thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah not North Carolina's
doing incest but like there was an
incident what is going on over there
insects
I love insects a there's some
country-ass places in North Carolina I
was there or other military and went to
this one Club and it was literally
imagine a house like a big house and
then they had like a a and P n type sign
built into the roof oh I think it's
called planet rock or something
plat planet rock those ghetto ass
[ __ ] I kept I was like coming from la
pata rock this does not look like a club
it was a house imagine like a house
there's a house party and then they had
a sign but then there's bouncers it's a
legit business money laundering it's a
weird place you're seeing the ozark know
really good everybody tell me some more
good if you like it makes you want to
money launderer but not because it's
like those big consequent a money
launderer i don't need someone else to
make me wanna money launderer boy it's
it like goes into the details of like
how he money launderers awesome I need
some kind of interesting what yeah but
my CPA will not let me have it because
you know you'll get in troubles all as
CPAs those a hall monitor ass no he
keeps me out of trouble but damn
sometimes I do think about a life of
crime and sometimes my mouth starts
watering like Oh cuz seems so fun cuz we
dabbled into it it's a money laundering
alright filming you know such a
elementary stage yeah we never went to
like criminal like you stole a gun from
a gas station and you were like haha
yeah along the lines of that yeah like I
never had this stuff anything in my
butthole and sneaked it somewhere yeah
do that you just did it for fun Z I
would like it if I can put that on my
criminal resume like it was another
skill that I had but I didn't have it
too many criminal skills but stuff that
Burt likes to bring up and now in
fantasy what I'm using has a storage
device like a kangaroo you know speaking
of president you know I did something
really bad recently where
you're like there's like this moment
where you know like you shouldn't joke
and what you should joke that's all the
time but I like I do in this situation
so there's a friend of mine who was she
just might go to prison for something
she did really bad for and so she's
about to get her said to see this month
and so I was seen her in a very long
time it sounds funny already
right and I was like and I saw I was and
before I what then I brought a friend
with me so he could keep you in check I
was like y'all don't make any prison
jokes right we just we met up each other
and the first thing she did she ate her
food she's like this tastes really good
I was like well you better enjoy that
good you're go to jail [ __ ] how can you
not know she was laughing but you could
tell she was a little hurt but I just
kept making fun of her another good
truth is the most fun jokes to me what
did you expect so it was just weird so
even like at the dinner - unless she
looked outside and I was like somebody
come to get you I just kept doing it
over it you know not being as funnier
than the truth that's yeah how can you
not it like is what her life is ending
that's [ __ ] up her life she lived her
life to beat the setup for his
punchlines yup yeah he did that herself
can you not seize that opportunity thank
you that's what I said the way you
started your story was perfect you did
something bad and I'm glad you're
repenting no I mean it would be better
if she made the joke on herself I can't
I couldn't wait for it though but I did
dodge a couple of them but then it just
it was like holding in a sneeze but then
we were allowed to like talk freely
after yeah I was so awkward cuz I
couldn't make fun and she can't talk
freely when she's inside
[Laughter]
burden this girl she's fine she's great
for now I like when I used to work in a
bank I've always there were two thoughts
are the first one is man if I rob this
bank can I get away with it like an
inside job did you really try planning
it like no never never because then
that's hypothetically planning no I
can't then I got scared and I'm like oh
no I can't do it
I always happen that if we planned
wherever I worked out not here not here
but in all the other places I always
hypothetically planned because I know
the inside I'm like okay if I do this
this is I'll cover all my tracks if you
keep doing that cause it the money is so
different though when you're a kid like
just even receiving like five bucks as a
kid I was like getting a million dollars
yeah twenty bucks is a million dollars
you know what I mean and then you get
older like you realize like how many
bills that you have so that's why I even
like this pile of money it doesn't look
as enticing to me as it would if I was
like a lot younger cuz this looks like
this'll hold me over you know how much
it is cuz you know it's not even a
hundred grand yeah yeah two thoughts yes
the first one was what would I be able
to rob what would you do someone else
came in robbed it yeah exactly and then
what would you think and then I got
scared to stop thinking about you scared
yourself oh so in the first one I'm like
damn I wouldn't deny God just God I
won't think about I won't think about so
then I stopped then the other what if I
rob all I don't think about this I'm
like the opposite yeah me too you're a
gambler though no cuz I think about it
and I and I have to stop myself from
doing it cuz I create a good plan I'm
like this plants fill prove no one
thought about it I should do it i
siphoned thousands of dollars from my
old work Wow okay he's just confession
goes away where did you say you would
like thousands of dollars from my
company I can't tell if you're lying or
not with my team it's a confession I'm
sorry statute of limitations you better
make sure this never find out how I did
it there's a statue another thing it's
it's past the time okay you know the law
I don't know if he's down there truth or
not I'm
I'm not believing it I'm so scared of
getting in trouble like I'm so scared
that even like I I broke a jar marinara
in the grocery store by accident one
time and I just read I bolted to like
the other side of the store I was like I
don't know who did that
that's even worse grandmas lips on that
[ __ ] and I just want to get in trouble
why would you get in trouble no no I'm
so scared of getting in trouble it's
worse running away you need a break like
a 12th century laws it was probably
Prague oh the expensive ones maybe was
like 537 my dad just scared me too much
about getting in trouble I feel really
bad about stealing yeah now have you
ever stolen
oh yeah oh yeah yeah but then I always
justified it so I always said like
companies have like loss like that loss
being yeah inventions insurance and like
barely factored into the counting right
and I thought I would always calculate
how much this company is working I'm
making like Target or whatever and I'm
like this store is probably making like
millions and [ __ ] a month it doesn't
even matter
like what's this hundred dollar gonna do
or whatever right yeah and I think what
a criminal does a lot is just justifies
their actions and minimizes what it is
so then they know there's no real
contact guilt behind it right like even
breaking into homes or whatever you
think oh these people are way more rich
than I am
they could afford it it doesn't matter
and this is when I was like 16 to like
18 I'm immature I'm not thinking right
but now it's like oh [ __ ] it's not even
just the money thing it hurts you feel
violated you feel like this [ __ ]
just broke into my [ __ ] yeah I feel like
raped home rape you know mm-hmm well
every crypt level criminal to occur is
justify murder right you know like
desert man or whatever yeah that's
different I can't even do that I can't
steal yep but I don't think stealing is
right good for you Joe he learned a
lesson
[Music]